Das ist wirklich faszinierend es gab ja schon länger vermutungen das leben wir auf der erde schon kurz nach ihrer entstehung
entstanden ist schon öfter wurden micro fossilen also
Versteinerte mikroben gefunden doch diese funde waren nicht eindeutig es gab zweifel daran ob es wirklich
Fossilien oder irgendetwas anderes war der beweis dass es wirklich fossilien sind wäre spektakulär
Solche funde während ein weiterer hinweis darauf dass es nur noch eine frage der zeit ist bis wir
Außerirdisches leben finden dann würde leben nämlich nahezu überall auch unter extremen bedingungen entstehen und jetzt ist es tatsächlich
passiert gänsehaut ein forschungsteam hat die wollen wirklich ältesten nachweise für leben auf unserem heimatplaneten
eindeutig als solche
Bestätigt um welche lebensformen es sich bei den fossilien handelt was das für zukünftige mars mission bedeutet und ob diese entdeckung
Tatsächlich endlich die antwort auf die große frage ist wann der große prozess des lebens seinen anfang nahm jetzt in klicks um
Science-fiction herzlich willkommen ach ja und nachdem ich das letzte video online gestellt. Habe ist etwas wirklich ihres passiert mehr dazu, am ende
Erst vor kurzem haben wir von einem sensationsfund berichtet damals ging es um spuren
aus altem gestein in kanada die wohl auch von lebenden organismen
Stammen könnten die vielleicht ältesten fossilien auf der erde ihr alter
3,77 bis zu 4,2 milliarden jahre im vergleich dazu unsere erde entstand vor rund
4,5 milliarden jahren also nur kurze zeit davor die erkenntnis kurz nach der entstehung der erde
Entstand wohl auch leben auf ihr doch einen kleinen haken an dieser story dann gibt es doch wenn der endgültige nachweis dass es sich hierbei
Eindeutig um erster lebensspuren handelt der konnte bislang noch nicht so 100 prozentiger sicherheit
Bestätigt werden doch der direkte nachweis von leben ist jetzt einem forschungsteam aus los angeles bei ähnlich alten fossilienfunden gelungen
Konkret geht es hier. Um gestein das bereits 1993
Im westen australiens entdeckt wurde bei den feinen verästelungen und linien mustern wurden rund
3,5 milliarden als soll es sich also tatsächlich
Um organisches material handeln das im gestein eingeschlossen wurde anders als ihr entdecker welchen job
bezweifelten andere forscherinnen und forscher weltweit seine interpretation dass es sich dabei
Um die ältesten spuren des lebens auf der erde handelt doch
Genau das will shop zusammen mit seinem team jetzt bewiesen haben bei den untersuchungen hat das us forschungsteam erstmals die
Isotopenzusammensetzung der promx analysiert und zwar mit einem see kennt sekundär ionen
massenspektrometern bei der analyse von organischen material ist vor allem das typische verhältnis der
kohlenstoff isotope 12 und 13 entscheidend und das ergebnis ist
sensationell denn es spiegelt
Genau diejenigen isotopenzusammensetzung wieder die man beim mikrobiellen lebensform erwarten würde dazu mit dem schopf
Das c 12 zu 10 13 verhältnis ist charakteristisch für die biologie unterschiedlicher organismen und jetzt haltet euch fest
Das forschungsteam weiß sogar um welche konkreten lebensformen es sich bei diesen fossilien gehandelt haben muss und zwar um
primitive aber
vielfältig und gruppen von gewesen und es wird ziemlich genau
beispielsweise bakterien die die sonne zur energiegewinnung genutzt haben gamma proteo bakterien die methan konsumieren sowie
sogenannte russian das sind quasi uhr bakterien die das gas methan
produzieren ihr wisst vielleicht was genau dieses gas die atmosphäre von damals ausgemacht hat neben bereits
ausgestorbenen organismen konnte das forschungsteam um william shop tatsächlich auch
lebensformen identifizieren die mikroben von heute extrem ähnlich sind für den us wissenschaftler ist damit endlich der riesige streit
um irdische lebensspuren geklärt das ergebnis seiner untersuchung nämlich dass bereits vor 3,5 milliarden jahren
unterschiedliche gruppen von mikroorganismen auf der erde lebten lässt schopf zufolge nur ein fazit zu
das leben muss schon einige zeit davor
seinen anfang genommen haben
Das ergebnis ist bedeutend denn es zeigt nicht nur wie lange es bereits leben auf unserem heimatplaneten gibt sondern auch wie schnell es sich unter
Extremen bedingungen entwickelt hat wir haben ja hier schon öfter darüber berichtet aber auch
Diese untersuchung macht mal wieder deutlich dass selbst unter den krassesten
extrembedingungen egal ob trocken kalt oder heiß
leben entsteht und sich zudem auch noch weiterentwickelt und ihr könnt es euch denken nur eine schlussfolgerung daraus macht sinn
nahezu auf allen
Exoplaneten mit wasser in der habitablen zone ist die wahrscheinlichkeit jetzt extrem groß. Leben zu entdecken wow
Genauso wie auf dem mars denn ich bin der überzeugung die unterschiede vom roten planeten zu den lebensbedingungen
An manchen orten der erde wie etwa der atacama wüste sind absolut minimal wie
Unfassbar großartig wäre es also wenn wir irgendwann die entdeckung machen würden dass das ganze universum nur so voll ist mit leben
Gänsehaut tour denn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema
zum thema außerirdische erfahren wollt dann meldet euch bei vox app an
Hier ist der link dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantie ihr könnt direkt
themenvorschläge machen oder andere ideen vorschlagen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken gestern name schon achtung festhalten
1000 gemacht und ich habe wirklich jede nachricht beantwortet ja und hier geht es weiter mit dafür klicken fossilien geben hinweise
Auf außerirdisches leben ja da war es alles noch nicht, so klar ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran